-Our first guests tonight
are 13-time
Grammy Award-winning musicians
and the highest-selling
U.S. female band in history.
Their latest album,
"Gaslighter," is available now
Please welcome to the show
the legendary Natalie Maines
Emily Strayer,
and Martie Maguire
of The Chicks.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Hi.
-How are you?
-Thanks for having us.
-It is lovely
to have you all here,
albeit virtually.
I know that two of you
are in Texas.
Natalie, you're in L.A.
How are you --
How have you handled quarantine?
-[ Laughs ] Splendidly.
It's amazing.
Yes, I would say
I'm definitely the most
sequestered of the three of us
But I did had to go to the DMV
which is a scary place
even without quarantine.
But my son turned 16
and wanted his driving test.
So I did battle that.
The scariest part of that
was the porta-potty.
-Yeah, well, they say
try to avoid the porta-potties
at the DMV at all costs.
-Yeah.
-But this is --
I think, is it Martie,
you also have 16-year-old twins.
Are they going through
their driving, as well?
-Um, they're about to.
-Okay.
-Yeah, they have permits,
but, yeah,
they just turned 16 in April
Two at the same time.
I'm terrified.
-Because of social distancing,
can you have sort of driving
instructors in a car with you?
How does that work now?
-No, and I have been out
a couple times
with one of them in particular
[ Laughing ] And it's
white-knuckling, you know.
So, yeah, I have my boyfrien
take them out,
because he's a lot
braver than I am.
-Yeah, I guess
if you don't have a special ca
where you have that driver's e
brake on the passenger side,
it can be a terrifying
experience.
-Yeah, quite.
[ Laughter ]
-And, Emily,
congratulations are in order
Is it your oldest
that's getting into college,
got into college?
-Yes. I got my first kid
off to college.
And we didn't have to set foot
on a campus.
We just did a drive-by,
just waved
and then looked at
all the majors that they had
and it was a good fit.
And he applied and got in.
And, so, I'm happy.
-That's --
Congratulations to him.
So he never walked around
the campus earlier in his life
It was just, it looked good,
and you drove by,
and that was enough?
-He's familiar
with that part of the country.
So I knew he knew the area
the people, and everything
It was just, we were just
looking for majors
more than anything.
But, yeah, we didn't do
any, you know, visits
or anything like that.
So it's probably good for him,
too, though.
-Well, that will make his --
Whenever he finally
gets on campus,
it will be
a whole new experience.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, congratulations
on the album.
It's fantastic
all the way through.
The title track is fantastic
But certainly,
the world we live in
interrupted the rollout
of this album,
up to including the fact
that we were going to all
get together in the spring
and day-drink together.
I was looking forward to i
a great deal.
Do you think you would hav
drank me under the table?
Is that --
Were you confident of that
-What's --
What's your drink of ch--
What would you
have been drinking?
-Well, I grabbed a tequila
right now, so --
-Well, that's what we drink.
-What do you guys have?
Do you have something?
-Tequila.
-Wine.
-Okay. Great. [ Laughs ]
-Red wine.
I'm sorry, rosé wine.
-I would say --
-Oh, well, I feel like
Martie would have been
under the table, then.
-Right, Martie's --
-We could drink you
under the table, I think.
-My tolerance has gone way u
during corona.
-Well, I think it broke
one way or the other, right?
I think people either
really built up their toleranc
or now people are
total lightweights.
-I'm scared, actually.
Every day, I ask my boyfriend,
"Do you think I'm an alcoholic
Do you think I'm an alcoholic?
[ Laughter ]
-And what does he say?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Excellent.
-I think historically,
the people
who have to ask every day
are usually
on the wrong side of it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right. Right. If I'm willin
to ask, I'm probably not.
-But Martie weighs
like 8 pounds,
so like two glasses of wine, and
she's just like really tipsy
[ Laughter ]
-What -- You know,
a lot of people, I think,
especially in the very
beginning of this,
wondered if this would be a time
that would increase or decreas
their creativity.
How did you find it as --
Was this a time that you sort of
thrived creatively,
or did you find yourself
being blocked?
-Uh, not musically.
Have not created a single note
But I always have craft projects
and house projects,
and around the holidays,
I've been making wreaths.
Would you like to see them
-I would love to see a wreath.
This is very exciting.
-I thought you might.
So I have them on hand.
-Oh, that's very nice!
That looks professional.
-Thank you. Etsy professional.
Here's one more.
Let's see.
[ Grunts ] This one's big.
This one is for you.
-Oh, my God!
That is absolutely --
Now, how long, start to finish
does it take
to make a wreath that size
-This one, I made yesterday.
And it took me...
I'm going to say six hours
-That's --
-Really? That's it?
-That seems about right.
-I binge-watched
"Real Housewives of Potomac"
and made that wreath.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know what could b
more Christmassy than that
Martie and Emily, were you aware
that Natalie was making wreaths?
Is this -- Are you guys
close enough as a band
that this information
made it to you?
-I didn't know specifically,
but I did not --
It was not a shock to me.
She's always doing
something, like, crafty.
One year, it was latch hooks
She was going to make --
-[ Laughing ] That's right
-And then, you know --
-I did the entire --
What's the supper,
the supper from the Bible?
-"The Last Supper"?
-"The Last Supper."
I latch-hooked
"The Last Supper."
[ Laughter ]
-Where is that?
Do you have that handy?
-I should stress to you guys
I'm not religious,
and I got that right away.
[ Laughter ]
-Which supper?
-I'm not real religious.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, she -- She did a painting.
You remember The Big Supper?
"I don't think
it's called that."
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, was it the first supper
or the second
to the last supper?
-Stick to wreaths.
-[ Laughing ] The last supper.
-Hey, this is --
You know, this is a very -
It seems to me that your fans,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
they --
When you guys release work
because you have fans that car
a great deal about your work
they try to delve
into the lyrics especially
and try to find meaning in them,
a brand of, I guess,
fan sleuthing.
Is that fun for you guys
when people do that,
and how close do they get?
-I don't watch
a whole lot of it,
but some of it's close.
Some of it's not.
[ Laughs ]
But, yeah, you know, we didn't
want to spell it all out.
We wanted people to get to
sort of decipher the album
for themselves.
And some of their guesses
that I've seen have been right
and some have not.
I will say, I do not own a boat.
And that seems to be
everyone's biggest question.
-Well, you should make one
You obviously are very crafty.
-Mm-hmm.
-You must all be excited.
You know,
there's a million reasons
to be excited
for this to be over.
But I imagine,
like, these are songs
that you haven't had much of
a chance to play live together
-Not at all.
-Yeah.
-We were supposed to go --
We were supposed
to release the album in May,
go on tour in June.
None of that happened.
We had to kind of fight with
the label to get the album out
'cause we just wanted everybod
to have the music.
But probably won't tour
for another year and a half.
-Well, when the time comes
that we can all be
in places and rooms together
I hope we can get our
day-drinking back on the books
It was a delight
to talk to you all.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thanks so much for having us.